the world bank has cut its global growth
forecast for this year warning of the
quote
sharpest economic slowdown in 80 years
the 4.1 percent economic growth that it
predicted has been slashed to 2.9
and the problem is being exacerbated in
america because the biden administration
would rather pursue its long-standing
leftist agenda killing fossil fuels for
example over helping the economy by say
expanding new oil and gas leases rather
than shutting them down which is what
they did
everyone knows that the economy is in
bad shape
everyone knows that biden isn't helping
and even biden's own spokesman can't
defend it what we have seen is historic
numbers is this we are in a historic uh
place in history uh historic place right
now as we have uh as we look at where we
are with the economy very very different
than where we were a year ago and that
is because of what the president has
been able to do with with a
comprehensive plan to get people
vaccinated with a plan to get people
back to work
we are in an historic moment in history
historically
corrine jean-pierre is no historian but
she is right about that historically
we are in a very different place than we
were a year ago last year when biden
took office gas was half the price that
it is right now
we were not engaged in an unnecessary
proxy war with a nuclear petrol state
raising energy prices around the world
grocery prices were not through the roof
we are in a very different place
economically than we were
last year and the difference is entirely
bad it's worse it's worse now everyone
knows it but not everyone is willing to
admit it or do the things that they
would need to do to fix it
what we're trying to say what i'm trying
to say to you is that the economy is in
a better place than it has been
historically and so we feel here at this
administration and other experts as well
is that we feel that we are in a good
position to take on inflation we are in
a good position to really start
really working on lowering prices
that just isn't true historically or
presently that just isn't true and it
isn't just
not true
it's a lie
these people know that the economy is in
terrible shape
they just don't care they care in the
sense that it might hurt their
short-term chances in the elections but
they don't care enough to give up their
radical long-term agenda
that's what the democrats are thinking
on the economy that's what they're
thinking culturally on transiting the
kids that's what they're thinking on
criminal justice letting all the
criminals out of jail it's true on every
political front
the democrats are taking a short-term
hit right now which is all well and good
but they're only doing it because they
think it will help them win the
long-term war i'm michael knowles this
is the michael nols show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from christian
thompson who says we're going to need
the daily wire to make a new documentary
for everything the liberals can't define
next up
what is democracy
what is a democracy well a democracy is
a form of government that identifies as
a democracy yeah but what is that
these days it's actually it's a perfect
analogy that's a very astute comment
because just as
a man now can identify as a woman so too
an oligarchy can identify as a democracy
and that's what the democrats say our
sacred sacred democracy
of us totally crooked
generally unaccountable elites that's we
need we need some new representatives if
you ask me i wish we could hire them
through zip recruiter you can certainly
you can certainly improve your business
personnel through ziprecruiter right now
go to ziprecruiter.com
knowles there are so many things to do
during the summer you want to be as free
as you possibly can to enjoy them so if
you're a business owner
do you want to be wasting your time
sorting through tons of unqualified
candidates resumes when you could be
sitting by the pool sipping a nice pina
colada going to visit a friend taking
your family on a nice little vacation go
cooking hot dogs on the fourth of july
that's what you want to be doing that's
why you need zip recruiter to find great
candidates ziprecruiter does the work
for you and right now you can try it for
free at zipruder.com knowles they use
powerful technology to find and match
the right candidates with your job
they've got a complete suite of tools
makes it easy to filter review rate your
candidates four out of five employers
who post unzip recruiter get a quality
candidate within the first day that's
why zip recruiter is the number one
rated hiring site based on g2
satisfaction ratings as of january 1st
2022 soak up all that summer has to
offer let zip recruiter do the work for
you the url is ziprecruiter.com
knowles that's where you can try it for
free ziprecruiter.com canon wles zip
recruiter the smartest way to hire
people are really
hurting
gas prices are through the roof my wife
bought eggs the other day and my wife
does like fancy eggs she wants her eggs
to have gotten a manicure and a pedicure
in a college education that's true but
still there's a limit to how expensive
eggs should be or so i thought
for 18 eggs do you know how much she
paid
she paid almost nine dollars
that is criminal that something has gone
seriously wrong
milk prices are through the roof not
even just for the fancy college-educated
milk but for all the milk it's it's
insane what people are paying right now
it's especially true when it comes to
energy so we've got to do something to
fix it if i were president right now
this isn't very complicated i would well
the first thing i would do is
not do what joe biden did namely
restrict new oil and gas leases when he
came into office he said okay no more
new oil and gas leases it's going to
what's that going to do it's going to
raise the cost of energy what does he do
he starts killing oil pipelines what is
he and they say well the oil pipelines
they weren't going to go into effect for
a year or two okay well here we are
we're a year or two out i sure wish we
had an oil pipeline right now then what
does he do he gives the green light to
vladimir putin's oil pipeline so that
that gives vladimir putin the
opportunity to invade ukraine and what
does that do it drives energy prices up
around the world this isn't extremely
complicated stuff there are really basic
things that you could do right now but
the democrats don't want to do that
because it cut cuts against their much
longer term global warming agenda to get
america off of the types of energies
that they hate
and onto the kinds of energies that they
love and the kinds of energies that line
their own pockets
what does the democratic senator
debbie stabenow say
her constituents are pleading they're
saying we can't fill up at the pump
we're not going to be able to heat our
homes we're not going to be able to pay
for certainly air conditioning in the
summer and what about the heat in the
winter and she says well
dummies why don't you just go buy an
electric car
i dress to say just on the issue of
gas prices after waiting for a long time
to have enough trips in this country to
finally get my electric vehicle i got it
and drove it from michigan to here uh
this last weekend and went by every
single gas station and didn't matter how
high it was and so i'm looking forward
to the opportunity for us to move to
vehicles that aren't going to be
dependent on the
whims of the oil companies and the
international markets
people accuse marie antoinette of having
said let them eat cake when she was told
that the the peasants didn't have any
bread to eat it's not true by the way it
was just completely made up she never
said that
marie antoinette one of the most
unfairly maligned characters in history
but but nevertheless debbie stabenow
really did say that
debbie stabiner really did say yeah
people are really really upset about gas
well the other day i'm tooling around in
my nice new electric car and i didn't
have to worry about any of those gas
stations so you know look you're having
trouble affording gas which is now about
five dollars a gallon on average
nationwide in some places it's gonna go
to seven or eight dollars
wait you're having trouble paying for
that buy a fifty thousand dollar car
idiot what's what's wrong with you just
go buy a tesla you don't even need the
model x you can get the model s
okay it's not that expensive you don't
have to spend 96 thousand dollars you
can spend 48 thousand dollars you know
plus tax okay so it's a little over 50.
what's the big deal stop complaining
that way you don't need to worry about
paying five dollars a gallon for gas
that's what they
they really mean that it's not just that
they're so out of touch that they keep
stepping in it they they keep putting
their foots in their mouths
they genuinely believe this is a great
opportunity to get people off of
old-fashioned guards and get them to go
buy teslas
janet yellen treasury secretary
says that this is a great opportunity to
make america more dependent on solar and
wind energy given the global nature of
these markets
it's virtually impossible for us to
insulate ourselves from shocks like the
ones that are occurring
in russia that move global oil prices
and look over the medium term the
critical thing is that we become more
dependent on the wind in the sun that
are not subject to geopolitical
influences and passing clean
energy credits that will
boost
non-renewables
is i think really
really critical to
um
to to to addressing climate change and
our uh energy costs for households
there it is do you see how she slipped
up
she's going on and on for whatever
reason the treasury secretary is just
going on and on about what american
energy policy should be
and she keeps saying it's all about
solar it's all about solar it's all
about solar it's all about wind and then
she says it's really important for
addressing climate change i mean the
energy crisis
let's see because you're right
if if you believe that the sun monster
is going to kill us all if you believe
the world is going to end in 10 years
now i guess it's a shorter timeframe
than that because they made the
prediction some years ago now if you
believe that
oil and gas are going to kill us all if
you believe if you believe all the
premises of global warming
then and if you believe that the solar
panels being manufactured in china are
not worse for the environment than
fossil fuels are which by the way that's
a pretty open debate but if you believe
all of that then yeah okay you think
it's really important to move to solar
but not to solve the energy crisis
because solar is not as efficient you
think it's important to move to solar
so that we save the world from the
horrible rising temperatures in the sea
levels it's not to solve the energy
crisis they're doing a little bit of a
bait and switch here
they're saying yeah you hate those high
gas prices well we're gonna we're gonna
fix that problem with solar energy but
the problem they're fixing is not your
high gas prices or
energy prices broadly the problem that
they are fixing
is global warming in their views and
janet yellen is it does not have a lot
of credibility here she's the treasury
secretary but she's been dead wrong in a
lot of her predictions she was dead
wrong about her predictions on inflation
was it a mistake madam secretary to
downplay this inflation risk did that
contribute to the problems we're all
seeing right now
well um look i i think i was wrong then
about um the path that inflation
would take as i mentioned there have
been unanticipated
and large shocks to the economy that
have boosted
energy and food prices and
supply bottlenecks
so good on her for admitting that she
was wrong a lot of politicians refuse
steadfastly ever to admit that they're
wrong but she was wrong and the biden
administration broadly was wrong in
their economic predictions and so i
don't really see why we should believe
them now and when they tell us now don't
worry this is just a blip the economy is
actually in good shape we just got to
make some more investments into solar
energy we've just got to invoke the
defense production act for some reason
to to give more money to solar energy
companies and line the pockets of
democrats we've got don't worry and then
it'll all work out fine i don't see any
reason to believe it every time they've
told us that the situation is going to
get better things have gotten much much
worse buildback better has completely
gutted the economy and shaken the world
order we're we're what a year and a half
into this thing how much how much
further can we fall joe biden is
screwing up royally
and
the the reason that we're dealing with a
terrible economy right now and a threat
to the world order and record high
immigration and crime spiking everywhere
the reason we're witnessing this
national implosion right now and
everything getting much worse
is so that we could avoid all those mean
tweets
because donald trump was a mean guy and
and joe biden's a nice guy
and he's going to return us to to be a
good civil nation he said he was running
to restore the soul of the nation and
this is a point i i have to get to i
have to address because beyond all of
the policy failures of biden this i
think is the biggest lie about the man
that he's just a nice old guy he's not a
nice guy he's a bad guy he's a mean
nasty dishonest bad guy
and that's an occupational hazard of
politics but it's especially pronounced
with joe biden
and you see the man's character on one
issue in particular that happens to have
cropped up in the news again
joe biden will not acknowledge one of
his grandchildren
this
is a national scandal and this should be
a much bigger deal this really tells you
something about his character
he steadfastly refuses to acknowledge
his granddaughter that was conceived
by his son hunter and a stripper and
because of the inconvenient facts of
this conception and then birth
joe biden he'll hang up stockings at the
white house for all of his grandchildren
except for this one grandchild
and now this grandchild is receiving
threats from her mother's ex-fiancee
the the mother
london roberts i believe her name is was
engaged to this guy and the guy is a
total nut he's a former amateur mma
fighter and now he's threatening roberts
and
roberts's daughter joe biden's
granddaughter
and threatening to take the daughter
and roberts is going and trying to get
court orders against this guy and he's
apparently banging on the door in the
middle of the night he carries a firearm
and roberts just said that she was
cowering with her daughter behind a
couch with a gun waiting to i mean it's
a really bad situation and now a friend
of roberts is speaking out about this
because for a while i thought look maybe
joe biden actually is
in touch with the granddaughter but he's
keeping it kind of secret maybe to
protect her privacy or something but
apparently that's not the case a friend
of roberts said the president frequently
talks about his love and pride for his
grandchildren but if he really cared for
every member of his family he would have
done something by now
the secret service would act at the drop
of a dime if someone threatened any of
the other biden kids but it's like
this granddaughter or navy joan doesn't
matter
and the the gal roberts is doing
everything she needs to to keep her
daughter safe with without the biden's
help
so not only is biden refusing to act
this is the most powerful man in the
world he's not even acting to protect
his poor little grandchild when the
little granddaughter is being threatened
by some lunatic guy
he's not even acknowledging her imagine
you're this little girl
this is i i don't like joe biden and i'm
willing to take a lot of political shots
at him but take your politics out of it
for a second let's say you're a democrat
let's say you voted for joe biden just
take your politics out of it for a
second just look at it as a
granddaughter and a grandfather you know
that your grandfather is the most
powerful man in the world the president
of the united states
and you grow up knowing that he won't
even acknowledge you because he's
ashamed of you because he doesn't like
the facts of your birth he doesn't like
that you're around he finds you
inconvenient
it's a nasty awful thing to grow up with
and he's a nasty awful man for doing it
it's as simple as that
and and especially cruel in this case
because the girl apparently faces a very
credible threat to her life and to the
life of her mother
no acknowledgement whatsoever nice
that's nice guy joe biden at least we
don't have the mean tweets donald trump
is mother freaking teresa compared to
this guy it's so it's so disgusting
speaking of children speaking of
inconvenient conceptions and births
there's a pro-life pregnancy center in
buffalo new york
that has just been attacked you if you
listen to this show if you listen to
a handful of conservative outlets you
will know that there have been major
attacks arson vandalism on pro-life
pregnancy centers in recent weeks and
now there's another one
this pro-life group compass care was
attacked early
yesterday morning
this is all about the potential
overruling of roe v wade which could
come out now anytime
vandals broke windows and they set fire
to the medical office at
comfort compass care they wrote graffiti
with the words jane was here this is the
phrase used by jane's revenge which is a
leftist terrorist group that attacks
pro-life pregnancy centers they also
took credit for a fire bombing at a
pro-life center in madison wisconsin
last month you won't hear about this in
the liberal media but but it ties into
something we were talking about
yesterday
which is
the libs do not really care about the
people that they are pretending to care
about
the libs care about ex exploiting people
and situations to advance an agenda that
they already had
before the people that they're
pretending to care about were involved
so a good example of this would be
energy we were just talking about
the libs want to push solar panels
pushing solar panels is not going to
bring energy costs down anytime soon
the libs are not going to do the things
that they need to do to bring energy
costs down soon namely open up oil and
gas drilling they're not going to do
that
but they are going to exploit the pain
that people are feeling right now
to get the long-standing agenda there
have been
high-profile shootings recently
the laws that the libs are proposing
right now to ban the ar-15 for instance
would not have stopped any of these
shootings that occurred recently
they wouldn't have stopped any of the
shootings in recent years
not just the ones in the past few weeks
but the past 10 years 20 years wouldn't
have stopped any of them
and and the smart libs know that
but they are exploiting the pain of the
people who are who were affected by the
shootings and the people who are
sympathetic to those who are affected to
try to push their long-standing gun
agenda
same thing here we're told that this the
the overruling of roe v wade is an
attack on pregnant women this is an
attack on women's health care you want
to talk about an attack on women's
health care you keep fire bombing
pregnancy clinics
how about you you don't want to attack
women's healthcare stop firebombing the
pro-life pregnancy centers now there are
pregnant women who cannot get care
several several places right now
pregnant women cannot get care not
because the court is going to overrule
roe v wade but because leftist
terrorists are bombing them in in
buffalo in madison elsewhere
that's why but they don't really care
about the pregnant women they just care
about their sacrament of abortion and if
pregnant women need to be hurt if
disproportionately poor
disproportionately minority
disproportionately underserved women are
being hurt by that well so what you got
to crack some eggs to make an omelet
these days it's very expensive to crack
eggs to make an omelet but that's the
way that they're thinking
okay the actual pregnant women get hurt
but
my long-standing agenda
that gets to be
advanced
and you won't you won't hear about it in
the media other than on this show and on
a handful of other conservative outlets
it's a total double standard there was a
story came out the other day did you see
this story
in yahoo news
but there were it was being reported
lots and lots of places
witness says police shot an unarmed
pregnant woman five times and cuffed her
wow those racist awful disgusting
terrible police shooting an unarmed
pregnant woman i saw that headline
popped up i said i don't think that's
true
i bet there's more to the story
i just reflexively don't believe the
media reports
and then what happens
turns out uh it's not true
turns out that the woman
is
was not
pregnant and she wasn't unarmed she
actually had a gun and she was pointing
the gun and she had just tried to jack a
police car and so finally or not a
police car she tried to jack a regular
car the police come up she's not
pregnant she's got a gun she's pointing
the gun and then the cops fire on her
totally justified
the headline completely made up
promoted everywhere in the liberal media
then it turns out it wasn't true and
what happens do you get a big giant
correction no the story just kind of
goes away
okay never mind moving on
darn that's too big we thought we had a
good one we thought we had a good excuse
to push our agenda but now okay never
mind
we'll get him next time don't worry guys
it's not
even the way that the the news media are
used it's totally instrumental
so you'll and it's the same
sort of thing we're talking about with
energy with women's rights with with all
sorts it's all just instrumental you
sometimes hear of the news media calling
themselves we're the we're the fourth
estate oh yes we're the brave intrepid
journalists who are out there standing
speaking truth to power no they're
they're instrumental they're tools
they're used to advance the leftist
agenda and so when when a story does
that they run with it and when a story
doesn't do that they kill it that's why
we try to tell the other stories that's
why we try to tell important stories
that's why we try to get to the question
the most important question of our age
what is a woman
out now if you want to watch matt's
movie what is a woman you've got to be a
daily wire subscriber terror on the
prairie the big movie that is
uncancelling gina carano it's got nick
seriously in it i can't wait that's
premiering very very soon you want to
watch it you got to become a daily wire
member head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe
join us get exclusive access to our
entire library of content and and help
us push back against the extremely
corrupt liberal establishment media we
need your help to do it we're so
supportive or we're so appreciative
rather of those of you who have
supported us so far we'll be right back
with a lot more
in case you had forgotten
it's pride month i don't think you could
forget that it's pride month because
there are rainbows covering just about
every single inch of this country of
ours you it is inescapable the
corporations the media the entertainment
the government it's all sports now it's
all covered in the rainbow well what
happens if you disagree with the rainbow
i disagree with the rainbow
i'm catholic
and we don't we we
oppose the rainbow we don't think that
men can secretly become women
the
christians have a particular view of
sexual ethics
jews for that matter do as well muslims
do as well certain agnostic people do as
well they disagree not to be cruel not
to say we hate you you awful people we
just say look that's not our view of
human nature and sexual ethics in our
relationship to our bodies and one to
another and to our god so we disagree
with that but you're not allowed to
disagree with that anymore there were
some baseball players
who just decided that they weren't going
to wear the pride flag on their uniform
they didn't they just didn't want to
wear the rainbow they felt that it
contradicted their religious belief and
espn this woman at espn sarah spain blew
a gasket
tampa pitcher jason adam to the tampa
bay times hard decision because
ultimately we all said we want is them
to know that they are welcome and loved
here but when we put it on our bodies i
think a lot of guys decided that it's
just a lifestyle that maybe i that they
look down on or anything or differently
it's just that maybe we don't want to
encourage if it we believe in jesus
who's encouraged us to live a lifestyle
that would abstain from that behavior
sarah spain how does that all come off
to you
pride is about inclusion so you don't
love them and you don't welcome them if
you're not willing to wear the patch and
calling it a lifestyle reveals to me
that you've done not even a modicum of
research or understanding on this topic
it's what tends to happen when a
privileged class isn't affected by
things this is not just about baseball
that religious exemption bs which is
used in sport and otherwise also allows
for people to be denied health care jobs
apartments
children
prescriptions all sorts of rights and so
we have to stop tiptoeing around because
we're trying to protect people who are
trying to be bigoted from asking for
them to be exempt from it when the very
people that they are bigoted against are
suffering the consequences when you say
trying to be bigoted
they're trying to use religious
exemptions
to affect the opportunities
services
of available resources for people who
are lgbtq plus
it's bs those religious exemptions
you don't have a right to your religious
exemption wear the rainbow patch that's
where we are we went from
tolerance hey come on it doesn't affect
you just let people be people let them
do what they want to do
to you will wear the patch or we will
ostracize you from society
we went from hey you know let people who
are a little quirky kind of maybe
explore what they to drag the kids to
the drag show
drag the kids to drag night that's what
they were calling that disgusting event
in dallas
dr drag the kids to a gay bar so that
they can put dollar bills in the thongs
of of deviant men dressed up as women in
front of a sign that says it isn't going
to lick itself that's that's
and we got there in about
six years
it wasn't a very long time
she says this woman is making the
argument that you you can't tolerate
intolerance that tolerance means
that you've got to wear the patch and
that if you refuse to wear the patch
you're not being tolerant of the rainbow
of lgbt and so that should not be
tolerated that you are a bigot
it is not bigotry to oppose lgbt the
rainbow that is not bigotry bigotry is
the unreasonable attachment to a belief
or a cause
opposing transiting the kids is not
unreasonable transiting the kids is
unreasonable
the transgender activists the lgbt
radicals
they are the bigoted ones that woman
sarah spain on espn she is a bigoted one
and she is a bigoted one specifically
because the beliefs of those baseball
players are reasonable beliefs they are
much more reasonable beliefs than the
drag the kids to drag night it isn't
going to lick itself perverts those are
un the beliefs held by those people
the beliefs held by sarah spain
and the
the rainbow gestapo those are
unreasonable
okay you will comply you will wear the
patch put the patch on that is that is
what's unreasonable it's not
unreasonable to say hey men and women
are made for one another and when a man
and a woman love each other very much
they come together and they get married
and they make baby and we shouldn't drag
baby to the 21 plus gay bars and have
them put dollar bills in the g strings
of weirdos
that's so it's a reasonable view to say
no to that but the point that she's
making that is really important
is
there's no such thing as total tolerance
this is actually a
central point in my book which is out
yesterday in paperback speechless
controlling words controlling minds this
book uh there it is wow i missed my old
bell it's so good to have that bell back
the book hit number one as a national
bestseller when it came out last year
it's old enough copies that now we've
got a paperback coming out the point of
this book was not just to own the libs
though certainly enjoyed owning the libs
a fair bit in the book but also to
correct some conservatives here who seem
to believe that we can just tolerate
everything they're the sort of people
who who say
you know whatever happened to the
tolerant left there is no such thing as
total tolerance
because
because either a man can become a woman
or a man can't become a woman
and and those two beliefs are mutually
exclusive and whichever belief a society
holds you're going to have to exclude
the other belief because you can't
simultaneously hold contradictory
beliefs that violates the law of
non-contradiction
you can't you can't tolerate everything
that's what that woman is saying if
we're gonna tolerate
lgbt if we're gonna be truly tolerant of
transiting the kids then we actually
can't tolerate christianity
or judaism
or islam
or normal traditional standards we can't
we have to pick one
and i for one call me a radical call me
crazy i think the old standards make a
whole lot more sense than drag the kids
to dragnite but the radicals on this
front
are getting much much more aggressive
there's a senator in california state
senator in california scott weiner
all nature is but art unknown to thee
all chance direction which thou canst
not see his name is weiner scott weiner
suggested in response to a texas
representative who who
proposed banning drag shows for minors
this guy senator weiner suggested
making drag shows for kids mandatory he
said quote
this guy this texas rep just gave me a
bill idea offering drag queen 101 as
part of the k through 12 curriculum
attending drag queen story time will
satisfy the requirement now this guy
scott weiner
this is not his first time proposing
this creepy sex stuff for kids this is
the guy who was pushing for easing the
sex offender requirements for people who
sodomize minors this this was a big
story what was it about a year or two
years ago
i said california thinks that the law is
just too harsh on people who sodomize
minors and we need to go a little
lighter on them that's fair so not
surprised that weiner would push this
kind of thing
but now he's saying we we need to make
this a part of the curriculum and i get
why he's doing it
i get why he's doing it he thinks that
he's owning the conservatives here this
guy gave me an idea i know what we're
going to do we're going to make this
part of the curriculum
yeah i know i know you're going to do
that that's what you've told us you're
going to do for years
yeah you're totally you're going to
totally own the conservatives by
proving that we were right the entire
time about your intentions yeah of
course you were going to do this
because a society has to have standards
and taboos because a society can't
tolerate everything and so
if we are going to cultivate a society
in which people are
open to drag shows for everybody then we
need to do it we need to cultivate that
from a young age we need to educate
people into that idea so of course it's
going to end up in the education system
it has to
this this is one area where i think the
conservatives have made kind of a
mistake when they're talking about
the the don't say gay bill quote unquote
in florida the parental rights and
education bill
some conservatives have tried to find a
middle ground here
the the libs say we need to indoctrinate
the kids into lgbt and put them on
puberty blockers
and
the the people in the middle the people
to the right of them will sometimes say
well look
it's not about gay or straight it's just
don't talk about sex at all
don't just get it get that com but
that's that's actually not possible and
and the libs will point out no that's
not you can't that's not possible
because
sexuality is very important to human
nature so when that kindergarten teacher
reads the book to his class or her class
more likely about mama bear and b and
daddy bear
and baby bear all having dinner together
and eating a bowl of porridge that is a
kind of sexual lesson you're talking
about what family looks like what the
relationship between the sexes look like
no one has a problem with the teacher
reading that book to her class in
kindergarten we would have a problem if
the book were about mama bear and daddy
bear and daddy bear's boyfriend and
daddy bear's boyfriend's throuple and
his s m
club that he goes to on thursday nights
we would have a problem with that
they're they're both talking about
sexual relations
or at least sexual identities
the issue is not that someone is saying
anything about sex the issue is what
people are saying the issue is
the substance
and that's
that's what this guy understands that's
what the libs understand
and that's why the real conservative
position here is no there actually is a
difference and we as a society have the
right to say that certain behaviors are
normative or normal and should be
encouraged and other behaviors
maybe we shouldn't be cruel to people
because they engage in those behaviors
maybe we should maybe we shouldn't even
outlaw those behaviors but at least we
can discourage them at least we can say
they're not normal at least we should we
don't need to put them front and center
at least we don't need to force everyone
to put on the
rainbow flag and cheer along
along the sidelines for transiting the
kids we don't have to do that
we can say that
it's normal for a man and a woman who
love each other very much to go get
married and they should get married it's
good for them to get married and it's
good to to create children within that
marriage and there are certain behaviors
here that are good
we don't need to be mean to people who
don't who don't quite fit that mold
but a society has a right to standards
every society is going to have standards
anyway it's just now the standards we're
getting are dragged the kids to drag
night it isn't going to lick itself does
anyone want to live in that society
do gay guys want to live in that society
no
not not
relatively right-minded gay guys
do
do the re the only people who want to
live in that society are the political
radicals and there's no reason we should
give it to them
we need to be able to say no there is a
north carolina mayor
who just finally stood up and he said no
we're going to cut it out with the weird
drag queen stuff there's a mayor in
north carolina
who said on saturday that a the lgbt
pride drag queen story hour event has
been cancelled after backlash from his
constituents this is apex mayor jacques
gilbert wow that's a very
very cosmopolitan kind of name for the
middle of north carolina
he is former captain of the
apex police department
he said the event was shut down because
the community didn't want it now he's
catching
pushback from the radical left the
community has a right to say no to drag
queen story hour notice
the community didn't say no to the pride
parade
the community has every right to say we
don't want a pride parade we don't want
that we don't that's not doesn't
represent our views here and so we don't
want that we're not being mean to people
we're not tarring and feathering people
or sending them out of the community but
we don't want
people dancing around the streets and
leather and rainbows we just don't but
they're not they're not saying that
they're saying no have the pride parade
they're not even saying no drag queens
they can even have drag queens
apparently this this
community is so
liberal
so
leftist so open-minded by the
by the standards of
pretty much every society everywhere in
the world where they drew the line was
don't
bring the kids specifically to watch the
drag queens dance around and read them
stories
just leave the little kids out of it and
that that's too much for the radical
left that's how far the overton window
has shifted that's how far back into the
corner conservatives have been pushed
that now the fight we're having is hey
maybe wait till the kid turns seven to
trans him
to expose him to drag queen shows
hey maybe don't maybe don't let the kid
go into the it's not gonna lick itself
show until he gets a lit just a little
tiny bit older you realize how much
ground we've lost there
the reason we've lost that ground is
because we've been duped by the left
into believing that we don't have any
right to articulate standards those guys
are articulating standards why aren't we
allowed to do it they're articulating
bad standards why can't we articulate
good standards if you want if you want
to know how we can try to reverse that
course you can read it in my book my
book that came out last year and then
just came out again i just came out
again yesterday there it is speechless
controlling roots controlling minds
available wherever fine number one
national bestsellers that have been
snubbed by the new york times bestseller
list are
sold
we've got
to protect ourselves and speaking of
protecting the public the cdc
is back to fear-mongering not about the
coronavirus
not even about the omicron or the beta
cron or the delta or the
epsilon or no
they're worrying us about
monkey pucks
there are now 31 confirmed cases of
monkey pox in 13 states in the united
states
monkey pox can be a very serious illness
though there are some strains that
appear to be less serious
the cdc is suggesting that right now
people avoid eating or preparing meat
from wild game bush meat so no eating
monkeys don't go out there and get any
monkeys in the trees and cook them up
they're suggesting we avoid using
products derived from wild animals from
africa
creams lotions and powders it's not in
my medicine cabinet right now but for
some people maybe it is you go to some
shaman to find some weird aphrodisiac
out of a rhinoceros horn or something
maybe don't
don't necessarily do that
and then the cdc said
that maybe people should wear a mask
they said wearing a mask can help
protect you from many diseases including
monkey pox and then right when the cdc
posted that
some
careful detail-minded conservatives saw
it and they said wait a second the cdc
wants us to put the masks on this time
it's because of monkey box and then the
cdc took it down
it was up but it was down and they're
moving the goal posts
they're saying darn kovid's over we
can't control them through covet anymore
maybe we'll do it through monkey pox
we're not going to tell them about where
monkey puck started by the way
definitely not this month we're not
going to talk about any parties in
belgium or spain it might be a little
politically incorrect to mention where
monkey pox started no no
but we are we can will you put the mask
on no you're still not you don't want to
wear the mask okay we'll try to but it's
all
it's all a power struggle you're now
hearing about another surge in
coronavirus the the biden administration
is still fighting to make you wear the
mask on airplanes again
this stuff is not
going away
there are there are pretty basic
preventative measures you can take to
avoid the monkey pox
if you'd if you generally if you avoid
orgies in belgium you're probably going
to be okay
but the cdc is not not saying that
because it's all just a way to
fearmonger 13 cases i'm sorry 31 cases
in 13 states we've been hearing about
monkey pox for weeks now good that's
good news it sounds like it's not a big
pandemic okay great wonderful
but they're always just waiting a little
bit to keep you on your toes to keep
that power for themselves up the delta's
back
shut down your business again oh you got
to vote by mail again oh you're gonna
it's it's all a way of reordering
society it's instrumental just like
every other political obsession that the
libs have speaking of
protection
there's a new scare pull out from cbs
news
that says that look we want to solve
gun violence in this country but we've
got a big problem it's those damned
republicans 44 of whom say that mass
shootings
are just inevitable
and so do they feel powerless or do
people believe they can do something
about it the good news is people think
this is preventable you get big
majorities that say it can be stopped it
can be prevented and it's not something
that we have to accept now there is a
quarter who says that unfortunately this
may be something that we have to accept
in a free society and i do want to point
out
some partisan difference here there is
bipartisan view that it can be prevented
but there are four in 10 republicans who
do say that it may be something we have
to accept and that partisan difference
is going to cut through a lot of this
margaret it's those damned republicans
those awful republicans the whole reason
of course that they're releasing this
report in this poll is to paint
republicans as being perfectly fine with
the mass killing of kids that's why
but they're not willing to do the things
that would
in a very practical way
lower the risk of kids getting killed
these republicans they won't ban the
ar-15
they say it's inevitable can you believe
that they value their ar-15s more than
they value your kids those awful
republicans
banning the ar-15 is not going to stop
mass shootings there is zero evidence
that that will happen
and in fact there's a lot of evidence on
the other side that that
probably wouldn't have that effect
actually when rubio made a similar point
back in 2015 even the washington post
admitted he was right that the major gun
control proposals from the left would
not have stopped any of the major mass
shootings
especially when we're talking about
shootings that take place in a confined
space
there's no like like a school like a
classroom there's no evidence that a
that banning one particular kind of
rifle which is used in relatively few
killings per year
relatively few homicides per year would
would stop things when people would stop
the massacres when people could just use
a handgun especially at close range
there's no evidence of that at all
how could you i i don't think that mass
shootings are inevitable
certainly not in schools but how could
you
what could you do to lower the risk of
mass shootings pretty simple lock the
doors of the school
pretty simple
have armed guards at the school
pretty simple
allow teachers
who are legal firearm owners to carry
weapons
pretty simple these mass shootings tend
to happen in gun-free zones i don't want
to sound like i'm just reciting
republican talking points but on in this
case let's say let's say you're a
democrat and you're listening and you
hate the republicans and you hate the
nra and you hate ted cruz and you hate
donald trump or whatever put that aside
for a second
do you think a shooter is more
likely or less likely to successfully
shoot up a school
if
all the doors except for one are locked
do you think that makes it more likely
or less likely obviously less likely we
all would agree with that do you think
a mass shooter is more or less likely to
shoot up a school if
there's a an armed guard there or two
armed guards
probably makes it less likely right
of course in the school let's go even
further do you think a mass shooter is
more likely or less likely to shoot up a
school or even to try to shoot up a
school if he doesn't even know how many
armed people are in the school he could
turn the corner and some teacher goes
and pops them off you just don't know
obviously less likely so there are
practical steps that the democrats could
take right now to dramatically lower the
risk
of mass shootings especially school
shootings
but they won't do it because they don't
really care about
preventing the shootings they care about
pushing the same long-standing mostly
unrelated gun proposals that they've had
for 30 years
and they're they only pretend to care
about the shootings because it's a tool
because it's an instrument to get what
they've wanted for a long time
this is no different than their plays
anywhere else on the economy and their
plays are are not particularly popular
right now it's failing on virtually
every front but they're playing the long
game their bet is that if they just keep
plugging away at this harder and harder
and consistently and longer and longer
and longer eventually even if they get
some short-term losses they're going to
win the long-term battle they're they're
seeing the victory more clearly than the
conservatives or maybe conservatives
need our own vision and our own courage
and our own stamina for a long-term
political fight maybe that would put us
in a stronger position to capitalize on
the absolute failures of the american
left i'm michael knowles is the michael
knowles show see tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
hey there this is john bickley daily
wire editor in chief and co-host of
morning wire on today's episode
californians take to the polls for key
votes wall street wades into the
abortion debate and a massive caravan of
migrants makes its way to the u.s
southern border join us and get the
facts first on the news you need to know
with our show morning wire